I've said before that voting Donald
Trump out is only the beginning and the
analogy I used was that for the last
three and a half years we've essentially
been playing defense we haven't had the
ball we've been trying to get the ball
back if Donald Trump is removed by Joe
Biden and becomes the next president and
Joe Biden becomes the next president we
haven't scored we've just gotten the
ball back and that's when the fight will
will really begin and it's important to
flush this out a little bit now because
we're now only four months from the
election Donald Trump is becoming
increasingly unhinged there's really two
ways in which voting Trump out will only
be the beginning Trump out she achieves
no progressive policy like just removing
Trump doesn't give progressives any kind
of policy victory we will only get
progressive policy done if and when
Trump leaves if we demand it from
whoever is the next president be it Joe
Biden or be it someone else in 2024 the
removal of Trump is the start of the
possibility of progressive policy change
but it's not actually any policy change
so in that sense getting Trump out is
only the beginning and I've talked about
that before but there's another side to
this which is really ugly and we have to
sort of come to terms with even if you
remove Donald Trump
you've not removed trumpism trumpism is
a virus that is going to be around for a
while and by trumpism I'm talking about
all of the really ugly stuff that we've
seen for years now the legacy of
nepotism and corruption and the
normalization of that in government the
mainstreaming of racism and xenophobia
that existed before Trump but it wasn't
so brazenly out in public that's one of
the things that Trump has done he's
coalesced and sort of said to the
xenophobes and racists come back out
into the public come back out you're
welcome now a ton of the behavior that
people felt ashamed about before and
would keep behind closed doors now it's
become almost glorified in some sense
that won't go away the day Trump is
removed the core singing of language as
I call it you know grab them by the
you-know-what making fun of people with
disabilities tweeting white power videos
I could go on and on and on with dozens
examples that's not going to go away
when Donald Trump leaves office and in
fact it could actually get worse if
Donald Trump loses and claims that it
was rigged we might see the absolute
worst of it come out with guns to
protest an election that Donald Trump
may use to convince his followers that
it was actually rigged against him so if
we see that type of violence it could
get worse before it actually gets better
and then what about Republicans we also
have to deal with the Republicans in the
House and Senate who have been gleefully
cheering Trump some of them others have
stood aside and allowed trumpism to take
hold and run rampant and I'm thinking of
people like Susan Collins who's
perpetually perpetually disappointed
with Trump but doesn't actually do
anything about it and arguably the
enablers are just as bad as the
cheerleaders none of that will be
removed just because Donald Trump is
removed in November so the point here is
not to put the cart before the horse and
pretend Biden's got this thing in the
bag we have won nothing yet we're still
trying to get the ball back
by removing Donald Trump in November if
and when that happens it could be this
November it could be November of 2024
that Trump leaves first of all we may
have to bear the brunt of a short period
of even more chaos and violence in the
streets from people who will simply
refuse to believe that Donald Trump lost
if indeed he loses in November but then
we've got to look at the Senate we have
to look at the house we have to look at
governor's and we have to look at the
culture that has been created to the
culture of Trump ISM and this is why I
keep talking about we get to vote in
multiple elections in November we get to
vote for Joe Biden but if you're in
Arizona you also get to vote for Mark
Kelly to replace martha mcsalley if
you're in montana you get to vote for
Joe Biden but you also can vote for
Steve Bullock to be elected senator Amy
McGrath in Kentucky all of these other
options where we can replace senators
who have either been actually supporting
Trump or standing aside and not getting
in Trump's way they are all part of the
problem and then when you look at
specific issues you really I mean it's
hard not to be pessimistic you realize
what we are up against if we
remove Trump in November we will have
lost four years when it comes to the
environment and to climate we can't get
those years back and so what that means
is that we're going to have to go above
and beyond even what we thought we would
have to deal with to handle the
destruction that Donald Trump has done
and I will go even further if even if
Joe Biden defeats Donald Trump in
November we are going to have trumpets
type candidates at least in 2020 to try
to get in possibly in 2024 so we're
going to have multiple election cycles
during which we will have to resist
these malignancies so that we can try to
end the national nightmare that is
trumpism so again let's not put the cart
before the horse your job is to envision
that when you go to vote in November
your vote could be the difference maker
between Trump wins your state and Biden
wins your state mathematically it's very
unlikely to come down to one vote but if
we all have that mentality none of us
will stay home we will all go out and
vote that's number one we don't put the
cart before the horse but remember that
you might also be voting on a Senate
race and if the right thing were to
happen in November then and only then
will we be able to say now the work
starts now we spend the transition
period figuring out how will we make
Biden as left as possible how will we
hold Biden accountable to the
concessions and there have been some
that he's made to the more progressive
wing of the Democratic Party that's
where it all starts and it's going to be
a very very long battle so you know last
week or the week before I got a phone
call from a viewer saying you know isn't
the Senate really more important because
even if we remove Biden but we don't
have the Senate we can't do that much
it's all important we get to vote for
president and we get to vote for senator
in some states of 35 races and we get to
vote for House of Representatives and
some governors and some state reps and
states that it all matters it's not one
or the other it's we should all
participate and we are going to have to
resist this viral virus
trumpism not only at every level in
November but likely for a few election
cycles to come and that is why I we just
have to keep the pressure up on all
aspects of this we have to keep the
pressure up from the perspective of
voter suppression we have to keep the
pressure up when it comes to the the TV
ads we have to keep the pressure up when
with these other online groups that are
putting together really good videos
targeting Trump we don't know what it is
that will make a difference when we look
back at 2016 was it commis second press
briefing about hillary was it Russian
social media campaigns was it Hillary
not visiting Wisconsin towards the end
of the there's you will never know the
one thing and when you have such a
complex election with 300 in a country
of 330 million about a hundred and
twenty hundred and thirty million votes
no one thing is ever going to be
definitively the difference-maker these
are all parts and that's why it's so
important we have a fantastic program
coming up for you today
later on I want to address this question
of how is Biden's lead today different
than Hillary's lead in 2016
nothing is a foregone conclusion but
there are some important differences
between the polling today and the
polling in 2016 and we're going to talk
about them we also are going to talk
about what will the debates between
Trump and Biden look like I know that
there are people convinced that one or
the other is going to absolutely implode
during the debates I'm not so sure we
are going to talk about that later today
and I also am going to dig into I
previewed this earlier in the week
how does Justice John Roberts fit in
ideologically compared to the people
Donald Trump has put on the Supreme
Court we're going to talk about the daka
decision the LGBT decision and the
abortion decision all of that coming up
today plus your phone calls make sure
you're following me on instagram at D
Pakman and make sure you are subscribed
for free to the daily audio podcast on
whichever is your favorite podcasting
platform
Spotify iTunes Google Play stitcher your
pick were
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are sharon sloan
and vicky Boyer Sharon and Vicki thank
you so much for your support also don't
want to forget to thank today's longtime
sustaining member of the day that's
James Baker James has been with us for
almost five years join these great
people become great yourself now you're
already great you would just be greater
grab a membership at join pakman.com
okay let's see what's on the audience's
minds we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 I want to go first to our
caller from the 6:09 area code caller
from 609 what's your name where you
calling from caller from 609 what's your
name where you calling from we can hear
you yeah what's going on John I had a
quick question for you I was calling you
know you're a student of the game market
the collapsing shadow banking oh my god
Sean you're coming in and out you're
saying what is the repo market correct
I'm hearing repo market collapsing
there's a shadow banking shadow banking
system
coop like oh my god Sean I'm sorry I'm
gonna have to let you go your connection
is just so bad it's and it sounds like
you're pretty busy there so let's see if
we can reconnect on on a better day
let's go next to our caller from the
eight one six area code who's calling
today from eight one six yes I can
my name is Trey I'm 18 years old and I
don't necessarily fit the mold of a
typical progressive I'm actually a
moderate and I wanted to hear your
thought process on this we talked about
Bernie Sanders inability to win over
black voters like myself and more
moderate voters right yes so and what we
saw in the South was the second time he
has the windboiler black voters not the
oldest Kurt
so if you believe that black voters and
I don't know this for sure but deep if
you believe that black voters are an
important portion of cranek electorate
then is it true that even though Biden
is no progressive he is he has a base
than Bernie does which was one of the
arguments of Bernie's about why you
should vote for him is that he just
could not all sorts of voters and in
build this giant tenth of a electorate
in order to defeat Donald Trump in the
hall well I don't I mean listen from a
personal standpoint of course I think
black voters are important as I mean
listen I don't want to write off any
portion of the electorate every portion
of the electorate is important but I
don't think we need to speculate about
you know there's Biden have a bigger
base by virtue of having more black
support Biden got way more votes in the
primary so from the perspective of the
Democratic primary even before Bernie
dropped out Biden was winning by around
1.8 1.9 million votes so I mean Biden
won because he had more people
supporting him I I guess I don't need I
don't feel the need to hypothesize about
whether it's specifically because of
black black voters Trump Biden had way
make way more voters in the primary when
it comes to Biden versus Trump it looks
like about 92% of black voters right now
are supporting Biden and we we can slice
and dice it in other ways but your
there's no question that Biden had more
support that's why he won the primary
yeah I just I wanted to understand that
because you know I talked to some people
and I always tell them you know if you
look at the primary where we reached the
last Super Tuesday before Bernie dropped
out I've watched some of your videos and
you talked about how oh my god okay I'm
gonna have to let you go you looks like
you you just cut out there let's go next
to our caller from the five one nine
area code who's calling today from five
one nine and just as importantly where
are you calling from David yes okay it's
Rowley from Owen Sound Ontario Canada
got a question for you yeah do you think
that maybe mr. Trump is just fed up with
the job and is deliberately trying to
sabotage his reelection I think he wants
to go golfing I think yes well you're
not the only all the hell he wants
yeah not have to take any responsibility
for it right what your views on that
listen Harry a few people have asked me
about this David Knight David I can't
hear you my phone's acting up so I'm
just gonna hang up and watch for your
response on the show sometime okay that
sounds fine listen I don't believe Trump
is consciously trying to sabotage or
sabotage his own election I think
Trump's ego won't let him do it but I do
believe that if Trump loses he will
justify it by saying hey you know what
it was rigged and I have plenty of
things to do I'm still a rich guy I'm
still going to be able to go and you
know do do whatever it is that I want so
I don't think Trump is deliberately
sabotaging himself I think from the
beginning Trump didn't really want to be
President and were the Republican
electorate
so easily bamboozled Abel if that's a
word Trump never would have become their
nominee and would never be president to
this day but yeah III think that if
Trump is trying to sabotage his election
he's doing it subconsciously not
consciously and then he will after the
fact certainly say I'm better off doing
doing other stuff anyway
let me pick up on our caller from the
five-0 area code not calling today from
five five three zero are you there yes
I'm here hello David yes how are you I'm
doing well I was just just called in I
was wondering what you thought about
third parties affecting the election
this time I voted third party last time
and obviously that can go very well and
man your connection is not sounding
great am i the one with the bad
connection today very bad I can hear
everybody excellent and you sound like
you're talking through a tin can
let me I'm actually calling from a
nuclear submarine is this any better yes
actually a little bit you're now at the
end of a hallway but it sounds better
good well I actually am in a hallway so
that makes sense
listen third party okay so I'm I don't
believe that the two-party system best
serves our interests I think that you
know the Republican and Democratic Party
represent really a quite a narrow scope
of the political spectrum we would be
better served with a much wider scope of
representation I also believe that for
as long as we have the campaign finance
system we have and the
first-past-the-post voting system that
we have it's going to be extraordinarily
difficult for third parties to really
make headway and in the short term they
will potentially have the spoiler effect
that it sounds like you might be
referring to from 2016 yep totally
I'm calling from Northern California
sorry I didn't mention that that's okay
okay all right well III hope I answered
your question I appreciate the phone
call I do think we are finally getting
the phones working properly which is
exciting let's go to our next caller
from the nine seven eight area code
who's calling today from nine seven
eight and where are you calling from hi
my name is Isaac
I'm calling from Massachusetts this is
just a phone number from Alabama I
believe love it okay I thought nine
seven eight was Massachusetts but go
ahead oh okay my bad um so yeah here's
my question uh how do you feel about the
current black lives matter movement
and do you think it will lead to
meaningful change and how do you feel
about how the movement currently doesn't
have like a current leader like a face
to lead the movement well listen I I
don't think it's my place to say whether
the movement should or shouldn't have a
face or a leader that's really up I I
don't even know to who because there's
no leader but I feel like it's up to
someone else to decide
I consider myself black lives matter
adjacent in so far as many of the goals
of black lives matter are the same goals
that I've been pushing for on this
program for a very long time my my
qualms with black lives matter as a
pseudo organization are on the record
that none of them I think will come as a
surprise to people since I've talked
about them before I believe that there
was at the time when the black lives
matter and women's march were sort of
overlapping I think they went in the
wrong direction from the standpoint of
having anti-semitic associated people
speaking for them and organizing events
I think that the way in which some black
lives matter chapters have thrown in
with the anti Israeli movement is
self-defeating and it's only going to
alienate what is really a natural
natural ally which is liberal American
Jews I think that they are going to be
alienated by some of the anti Israeli
language and stuff about you know the
fight for palace
Stein is the same thing that that black
look that you know we're fighting for
here against police brutality etc you're
starting to see really wacky stuff come
out like the reason police are a problem
in the u.s. is because they got training
from Israeli officials on trips and you
know like really really crazy stuff so
you know for me I don't really get too
involved in the in the groups and I've
not even talked about this for probably
more than a year but I'm glad you're
bringing it up but I am black lives
matter adjacent in that I support a lot
of the ideas that I think most of the
people support that are part of black
lives matter great yeah I believe like
the entire sentiment is very like I feel
like the public broadly approves of what
the fear and sentiment is for black
lives matter yes but like I feel like in
the media it's people are portraying
them as you know X Y & Z and I feel like
that might like ruin the reputation of
the movement so I was just hoping that
we could just move forward and talk
about what really matters about this
right well the thing is what really
matters to you or to me might be
different than what matters you know to
the people who are using black lives
matter to push Israeli BDS versus the
people who are using black lives matter
to say you know that what you know what
whatever I think the whole point is
there are things that will have
widespread agreement and then there are
areas where you you start to lose people
and I would focus on the lowest hanging
fruit that can achieve the most
meaningful change with the biggest
consensus okay great thank you so much
for your comments glad to be on your
show thank you so much thank you
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you let's go next to our caller
from the 2 for 8 area code who's calling
today from 2 4 8 ayat space from
Michigan hey ace what's going on hey
first of all love your show started
watching it listening to it about a year
ago
thank you I just want to say that so I
had two questions one was related to
your previous callers the black lives
movement back when it first started back
when joy Floyd was killed I think the
public the majority of the public had
their support in terms of police reform
now it seems like it's you know turning
into a very vague and doesn't really
have a direction or specifics of what
the people want and I don't know if
that's going to be good for the
Democrats especially coming into
November in terms of getting rid of
police or defunding all police and
things like that I wonder if you can
comment on that second question
yesterday Biden at some event made a
statement that he would reverse most of
trumps tax cuts yeah how how much do you
think that will affect the the moderates
in terms of their support for Biden
because I know they're probably more
conservatives in terms of tax I mean no
nobody wants more taxes to pay more
taxes Biden you know he's been doing
great in the tools nationally and that
most states especially you know the
swing states even I think today Texas
he's even with Trump but do you think
making any comments about reversing tax
cuts would be bad for him I mean he just
stinks why he's been doing great in the
polls just doing nothing but do you
think that helps or hurts him I think
that his comment about the tax cuts is
not going to have a big impact I think
that right now really what you have is a
referendum on coronavirus a referendum
on the economy as a result of Corona
a referendum on Trump's reaction to the
protests which has been abysmal and a
referendum essentially on Trump as the
laughingstock around the world that many
believe him to be so listen Joe Biden
has made it clear like nothing is going
to substantively change for the
privileged in the United States under
Joe Biden
so he'll reverse the Trump stack Trump
tax cuts or or let certain provisions
expire the very rich will pay a few
points more but again nothing will
fundamentally change it's these are
really just slight tweaks so I think at
this point because this is such a
referendum on Trump I don't think that
the tax cut comment is really going to
meet be a huge different difference
maker we'll see as the new polls come
out in the next seven to ten days now in
terms of black lives matter I don't
believe that what's going on with black
lives matter is going to hurt Democrats
in November at all I think as you
pointed out from the beginning on the
main issue that arias attention on black
lives matter right now which were the
protests that started after the death of
George Floyd overwhelming support for
police reform reform support for black
lives matter itself is way up compared
to where it was you know two months ago
or just before the start of this I think
really the only risk is what we've seen
Republicans already try to do which is
to couch the protesters as
overwhelmingly violent or criminal and
it's mostly failed I mean like Trump and
Caylee Mac and Annie you know they keep
pushing it but I think people pretty
much know at this point that protesters
are protesting and that's the majority
of what's going on and then other than
that you have other people who are
participating and doing bad acts but
they're really not representative of the
movement so no I don't think it's going
to hurt Democrats in November okay
yeah that makes sense one last thing you
know I've taken up a lot of time but
when do you think Biden will announce
his VP I think it's it should should be
obvious that it's Kamala Harris but you
know I think she would be the best bet
would he wait until the you know until
what they're called until the convention
yeah he said it'll be around its he's
gonna announce around August first is
what he said so I would expect you know
that's a month away I would expect that
will be uh roughly around that time all
right let's go to a quick break if
you're holding don't hang up because I
will go right back to the phones right
after this short break the david pakman
show at david pakman.com the David
Pakman show depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners and one way to
keep us going is through patreon where
you can pledge as little as one dollar
per month or as much as you want at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about him welcome back to the David
Pakman show ok let's go back to the
phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 a lot of
folks interested in chatting let's go to
our caller from the 636 area code caller
from 6:36 what's your name are you
calling from hello David this is Luke
hey Luke
so I have a pretty simple question so
you see the video of George Floyd and
that's really kind of seems to be what
set off these are current black lives
matter protests that we're having and I
just wonder like why is it that this is
the thing that finally set it all off do
you think it was just four years of
Trump and tension building up because
we've known for a long time that the
black community has been experiencing
all these and justices and nothing's
really set it off yet to this extent
anyway that's why it's a combination of
things I think you had number one a
population that is as unemployed as it
has been for a long time because of the
virus so you had a lot of people already
sort of
aching to get involved in something that
felt good
they weren't most people weren't going
to do the anti-mask protest because
that's idiotic most people understand
what's going on with the virus so you
had an incident that was on video it was
so egregious that even many people on
the right said hey this was wrong this
like I can agree even people on the
right and you know I'm gonna let you go
because there's some there's some kind
of noise there I'll answer offline so
you had people see the video of what
happened with George Floyd you had
overwhelming agreement that it was an
injustice you did not initially see the
officers arrested people are more home
than they've been for a long time and so
it was sort of like the perfect storm
then the president reacted in the worst
possible way by saying Oh protests
against police brutality I encourage the
governor's to dominate the protesters
and I'm sending in the military and that
exploded things even more so it was a
perfect storm of sorts would be my
perspective let me go next to our caller
from the five-10 area code who's calling
today from five-10
I mean yeah it is okay great um my
question is about I've heard a lot of
not not experts but sort of political
hobbyists like Bill Maher's they say
there on the left talk about how
identity politics and political
correctness has kind of been the key
feature of turning off moderate voters
that would have otherwise voted for
Clinton but instead voted for Trump it
seems like this is just kind of a
distraction and getting away from the
core issues of sort of centrist lukewarm
policies but I'd be curious to know if
there's any truth to it you know anytime
there's a question about what is the
thing that has led to something nothing
is ever that simple so to say like there
is no doubt that there are people that
have been turned off by the perception
that the Democratic Party is too focused
on identity politics there
also a lot of people who have
exaggerated the degree to which that's
the case in order to turn people off
like we have to understand when we're
being propagandized - there's a movement
that insists on saying the left is only
about identity politics at this point
and that makes people get turned off
even if it's not actually true so you
you you understand how sometimes that
can also be propaganda right yeah
absolutely everybody wondering if this
if there's any actual evidence or you
know not even any conclusive that is
there just some sort of evidence or any
kind of study taken I would suggest that
because it seems like just solely based
on the fact that I haven't been able to
find anything like that that it's kind
of a distraction from the question I've
not seen any evidence that what-what
lost it for Hillary what the difference
maker was was the perception of the
Democratic Party is too focused on
identity politics now you mentioned what
I call Republican light a lot of
Democrats being just slightly less
centrist versions of status quo
neoliberal politics I think that's a
much more serious critique and you've
seen a lot of Senate candidates even
presidential candidates who I mean
listen you know Republican Lite is sort
of a pejorative but it's it's true that
most Republicans know many Republicans
and most Democrats exist within a pretty
narrow range of the political spectrum
you've got a bunch of extreme
right-wingers now that are outside of
that and you've got some more left-wing
folks like Bernie Sanders who are maybe
outside of that but it is a fair
criticism that a lot of mainstream
politics is mainstream because it's all
sort of the same it's center left and
center right that's a good critique
right all right well thanks very much I
was sorry to see you the chess
competition was Jeff's trophy of the
tournament was not in your hands but
next time next time yes there is there
will be another one I'm actually I'll be
announcing when the third tournament is
going to be very very soon oh great
great
all right thank you for the call I
appreciate it hope to hear from you
again
let's go to our caller from the 7:01
area code who's calling from 7:01 today
hello yeah that's you okay sorry sorry
this is Nathan from North Dakota great
so my question is so I live about 100
miles south of the border of Canada and
North Dakota is a deep like in my
opinion deep Reds red state yes so if if
heaven forbid sound a little nervous
that's okay
it hasn't prepared that don't jump wins
another term yes what have you seen as
an act of cowardice to move to the north
to Canada um I mean I wouldn't call it
cowardice I would call it pragmatic it's
difficult to move to Canada so I don't
know that it's that easy to do but I
wouldn't see it as an act of cowardice
no I would see it as hey I'm taking
control of my life the election didn't
go my way I believe that this is such a
danger I don't want to be governed by
this orange maniac I'm going to go
somewhere else I mean if you it's good
work if you can get it so to speak like
it's difficult to move to Canada but if
you're able to do it I would not call
that cowardice at all mm-hmm yeah it's
just like with everything going on I was
just I don't think I could take another
another four years of living in a
country where just seeing what the
leader is doing so now could you move to
Canada like do you have relatives there
or how would you do it legally yes I
have about my mom's side I have an
entire set of family over there Wow
well that's certainly something to think
about you know a lot of people talk
about I'm going to move to Canada if X
or Y very few people ever really do it
so it would be it would be an
interesting thing to look at all right
thank you for the phone call I don't
know that we've ever had a caller from
North
the coda it's interesting let's go next
to our caller from the 8:32 area code
caller from 8:32 what's your name and
where are you calling from Hagen sent me
yes it is oh hi David
big fan thank you my name is Luis
Castillo hey Louis do I just have a
question yeah I've noticed in the press
briefings the presidential press
briefings yeah I was and I was just
wondering out do you know if there are
any progressive journalists in those
press briefings right because I know I
mean I know I don't know what Network
they're from but well they do say the
network they're from but I was just
wondering on do you know of any of them
if they're any journalists like from a
progressive news network there well it
depends on what you call progressive I
mean the the the journalists that are
there are not at least supposed to be
opinion people the oen people obviously
are right-wing loons there are people
who say oh yeah and CBS or left-wing but
of course the the people that are there
like you know Caitlyn Collins is there
for CNN I don't know her personal
politics I know adversarial
relationships exist between CNN and and
the Trump administration right now but I
don't know the politics of all the
people in the room because they're not
they're really supposed to be there as
reporters not as politically biased
individuals oh I see so so okay so like
the oen would be like the exception I
guess to the rule because I noticed that
it's do typically this young lady and
she doesn't even sit around yeah she's
absolutely bonkers her name is chanel
reown she she doesn't even understand
the questions she's asking she gets this
vacuous look in her eyes where she like
she has an idea of a question I don't
know if she has it written down but you
can tell she's having trouble parsing
the grammar of her own question in her
mind like she doesn't even know what
she's saying it's all very very weird
but for the most part what you have is
you know like Reuters has a reporter
there The Associated Press these are
people who obviously they have personal
political views but they're not really
supposed to be part of their role
as as part of the White House press
corps oh wow okay would you ever pick it
someone like you ever considered or
being that be considered to be in that
room I can't I can't imagine they would
they would ever grant me a grant me a
press pass lease I'm gonna let you go
okay your your audio is a bit
problematic but I I think I'm the last
person that is going to be allowed into
the press room and certainly if I were I
don't think I'd be allowed to to ask a
question let's go to our caller from the
nine five four area code who's calling
today from 954 David hey Derek what's
going on with Florida you are in the
epicenter of coronavirus that's right
okay take your time
[Laughter]
lot going on there sounds like a running
yes okay sorry um so yeah it's getting
pretty out here but wanted to hear your
take on the the 1d shooting with a
Rashard Brooks and whether the charges
are justified listen I I don't I don't
know I don't know that my position is
the same as with the George Floyd case
which is I don't know what the right
charges are we have a system I'm not a
prosecutor I'm not a lawyer I can look
at stuff and sort of say what happened
was wrong but in terms of the charges
there's strategy that goes into charges
there's evidentiary considerations i I
don't know what the right charges are
and that's similar to what I said in
terms of the charges against Derrick
shavon and the other officers I think
you know you you you really only know in
retrospect whether the charges were the
right charges and it has to do with the
evidence it has to do with a lot of
different things I just don't know the
answer mm-hmm so you think it was too
quick for the Atlanta DA to bring
charges I think it was just like a day
and a half they had like a special
investigation
I am I really just don't know but all of
these things are it's speculation from
the outside sometimes investigations
happen very quickly sometimes they
I think we're just not going to know
until more time goes by well my take on
it yeah I think this is one that upsets
people and it's very grey zone you know
the media was saying that he was
sleeping well really he was drunk the
media said he was unarmed but I mean he
stole the cops Pazar fired at the cop
and then the media said he was
nonviolent before arresting him if you
talk to any Sandling who's lost a life
to DUI
I'm sure they'll say that the violent
crime so you're saying that the fact
that he was potentially going to drive
drunk is an act of violence in a sense
court yeah I don't think that's actually
going to that that's a debate that is
not unique to this case I don't believe
that's actually going to be the
determining factor the guy was running
away he wasn't driving away so the fact
that we can debate whether driving drunk
is a violent act I don't think is going
to play a big role in what ultimately
happens okay yeah I appreciate it all
right my friend thank you I appreciate
the phone call but let's go to a break
that's all the time I have for today as
always I apologize I was not able to get
to everybody but we will take calls
again the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
ok let's get into audience questions for
the week there's a lot you can tell
we're getting close to this November
election and we are we're only about
four months away now because a lot of
the questions coming in from you guys
are about the November election the
first question is about polling and it's
about specifically comparing polling
right now to polling in 2016 the
question is David how does Biden's lead
against Trump today differ from
Hillary's lead against Trump in 2016 or
is this going to be a repeat of 2016 all
over again
where Trump wins by a small margin in a
few states excellent question
the first answer is we really don't know
until people vote which means every
single one of you should be imagining my
vote could determine whether Trump wins
my state or whether Biden wins my state
and you should go vote on that basis
that's number one now let's look at the
actual polls and look at differences
between Hillary's lead in 2016 and
Trump's lead in 2020 and Biden's lead in
2020 Hillary's popular vote lead in 2016
at the time of the election was smaller
than Biden's is today we've talked
before about how it can happen that you
lose the popular vote by a lot and win
electoral II that can happen you can
draw these maps where I think I saw one
over the weekend where you could have
22% of the popular vote and still win
the electoral college just because you
can make that scenario on a map doesn't
mean it's likely and so one of the big
differences between 2016 and 2020 is
that right now Biden's popular vote lead
is bigger than Hillary's was on election
day that can change the second important
difference between 2016 and 2020 is that
when you look at some of the states that
are likely to be the key states the
margin for Biden right now is far bigger
a Hillary in Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
and Michigan for example in 2016 you
look at
Michigan numbers right now they're
insane
so does that tell us they couldn't
change between now and November of
course they could change what it tells
us as the polls would have to change far
more dramatically than we've typically
seen them change in the last four months
and or the polls would need to be way
more wrong this year than they've been
in years past that's good for Joe Biden
the other sort of number two point two
is that Joe Biden is over 50% and well
over 50% nationally in a lot of polls
where is at this point in 2016 Hillary
Clinton was hitting 50 in some polls and
when she did it was usually like 50
maybe 51 Joe Biden has regularly been
hitting 50% in polls and the reason that
that's extra important right now is two
reasons one if Biden's already at 50 in
an important state for example he
doesn't need to worry about the
undecideds and the third party's I mean
yes he still wants to try to get them
but the point is he as long as he
retains the people he currently has can
win those states even if against an
incumbent as you get closer and closer
to Election Day more of the undecideds
might break for the incumbent in this
case Donald Trump so the 50% threshold
is also important and then that's the
last thing this incumbency factor 2016
was two challengers against each other
with an outgoing president now you could
make the case with an outgoing
Democratic president Barack Obama that
is a help for the Democratic candidate
Hillary Clinton okay that's not a factor
right now this is challenger versus
incumbent now in many ways the power of
incumbency does suggest the undecideds
as we get closer to November maybe some
third-party people maybe some people who
like Trump but aren't necessarily
thinking of voting might decide to vote
usually incumbency helps you as you get
closer to Election Day the concerning
number if you're Trump
is that as an incumbent in some polls
he's in the mid to high 30s that's very
very bad and that that as an incumbent
is a greater red flag then if this was
challenger against challenger you look
at Trump's high disapproval and you sort
of get an entire picture so in hearing
me talk about all of this
what should you take away from it
nothing absolutely nothing
you should be imagining I could turn my
state from Trump to Biden if I don't
vote that could be the vote that gives
my state to Trump if I do vote my vote
could be the vote that gives it to bite
now rarely is it actually a one vote
difference but the point is a lot of us
have these thoughts if all of us who
have these thoughts decided to stay home
Trump wins and that's the the most
important takeaway that I can imagine
hopefully we will all make the right
decisions in November and hopefully
November 4th will be you know it doesn't
have to be the big progressive victory
that we would all like it would still be
a major major improvement in the United
States and I hope to be there with you
when it happens okay a lot of questions
are also coming in about the debates
three debates have been agreed to in
principle between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump don't yet know when they will be
where they will be will there be an
audience I don't have the details yet
but the question I'm getting from a lot
of people is essentially how can we
expect Biden to do in debates against
Trump a lot of right-wingers are saying
Trump Biden dimentia Biden can't put
together a sentence so let's put aside
the hot takes about Biden can't speak
he's completely demanded at this point
III think that what we have to
understand is first of all historically
our expectations about this debate is
going to destroy this candidate or that
candidate that happens very rarely in
high-level politics in the United States
from my perspective Donald Trump so
thoroughly embarrassed himself against
Hillary Clinton in the debates in 2016
the debates did not move the needle
particularly and Trump ended up winning
as we all know when the Democratic
primary just a few months ago feels like
years ago but it was a few months ago
when the Democratic primary this year
got down to Bernie versus Biden you had
the same Biden dementia people saying as
soon as Bernie gets a shot against Biden
one on one Bernie's gonna crush him
Biden is not gonna be able to take it
and Biden did fine in that debate now
there are people who said after the fact
well it was because the moderators
helped by by making it all about
coronavirus over listen people some
people were convinced there was no way
Biden would even be able to string
together a sentence that was coherent
Biden did fine and went on to win the
the primary very very handily so if
you're expecting some Black Swan event
where we know every once in a while a
debate does change a race drastically
you're probably going to be disappointed
I do concede and I've been saying this
for a while Joe Biden at 78-77 is not
the Joe Biden that debated Paul Ryan for
example back in 2012 so I believe Biden
knows this I believe the people around
Biden know it so I would expect Biden to
train for a scenario that favors him so
knowing how to get under Trump's skin
without putting himself in situations
for maybe the type of rapid fire that
would not be playing to his strengths at
this point in time that that certainly
you know may be a case this has not you
know on the on the Trump side people
preparing him for the debate are going
to be probably in a futile manner trying
to get him to think about the debates in
a way where he won't end up saying
something racist or xenophobic or
discriminatory or or so you know I want
less testing because then we find fewer
cases or whatever so my vision is that
the debates are likely going to be
underwhelming for anybody expecting
really the types of fireworks that you
see once in a blue moon
that shake up a race remember according
to the polls Trump is going to be coming
into these debates playing from behind
but with the power of incumbency if Joe
Biden can simply and this is not an
endorsement of any policy if Joe Biden
can show up and present himself as the
elder statesman diplomat alongside this
unhinged wild wacky Trump doesn't have
to change that many minds that will
probably be good enough for Joe Biden to
maintain his lead
what else did I want oh one other thing
I wanted to mention there are people who
are hoping that the debates will be Joe
Biden calling out Trump's belligerents
and Trump's insane comments and Trump's
comments about women and about black
people and all this different stuff it
just doesn't really work that well right
I mean we've seen that it hasn't worked
well as something to hurt Trump during
the campaign and and during his
presidency what has really hurt Trump
recently has been failure on coronavirus
subsequent failure on the economy
failure on on his embarrassing response
to the protests against police brutality
that's where Biden should focus because
we've seen that the stuff that does just
float off or you know slide off of Trump
is the stuff about grab them by the
you-know-what where's my
african-american tweeting the white
power video I don't think that there's
really a winning strategy there for
Biden I think the strategy is look at
the stuff that's gone wrong Trump trying
to gut Obamacare during a pandemic right
that's where the focus should be from a
policy standpoint for Joe Biden hey
David we've seen John Roberts side with
the Liberals twice now once to not end
daca and this week with the Liberals on
abortion is John Roberts actually a
moderate justice has he become more
moderate
beautiful question this is really really
important we've heard in the wake of
these two decisions from the Supreme
Court where John Roberts was against
ending daca and against requiring
doctors who perform a
portions to have admitting privileges at
local hospitals and these were decisions
where John Roberts was with the Liberals
so to speak so I want to look at two
things here what do these decisions mean
about John Roberts politics but first
where is John Roberts politically
ideologically in terms of justices there
is a chart that uses a scale of plus
eight meaning ultra conservative down to
minus eight meaning ultra liberal four
Supreme Court justices this is something
that's done by Roberts and Quinn I'm
sorry Martin and Quinn on that scale
John Roberts started his Supreme Court
career at a 1.5 meaning on the right but
not as on the right as Clarence Thomas
for example he was a 1.5 and John
Roberts based on his decisions has been
moved down to 0.5 so he went from 1.5 to
0.5 0 would be a perfect moderate so
John Roberts according to Martin and
Quinn has moderated since joining the
Supreme Court okay for comparison
Clarence Thomas is like between a three
and a four much more conservative Samuel
Alito has gotten more conservative he's
gone from a 1.5 to like more than a 2 so
it does appear as though John Roberts is
certainly more moderate than some of
those other justices and John Roberts
has moved a little more to the middle
since joining the court here's the real
important question though
what do these specific decisions mean
about John Roberts ideology and it
really doesn't mean much and here's what
I mean by that these were mostly
technical decisions where John Roberts
was with the Liberals so andhaka John
Roberts didn't weigh in at all on the
merits of daca or the legality of daca
in some broader way the Trump
administration brought a very bad case
against daca the case the Trump
administration made was essentially
Obama didn't have the authority to do
daca the court rejected
that argument the court said merits
aside obama did have the authority to do
this
Roberts sided with the liberal justices
there on a technical matter and in fact
it should have been nine zero like it
was such an obvious easy decision this
was just a bad technical argument from
the Trump administration it should have
been nine nothing
Roberts was with the Liberals for
technical reasons
similarly this week in the abortion case
in Louisiana what the court found in its
majority decision and John Roberts was
on the side with the Liberals and wrote
the majority opinion was that if you
require abortion doctors better said
doctors who perform abortions I try to
avoid that term abortion doctors doctors
who perform abortions if you require
them to have admitting privileges at
certain hospitals you are in a technical
sense violating roe v wade which is
precedent it's established law and for
that technical reason John Roberts was
with the Liberals it was not about the
merits of abortion the morality of
abortion or anything else so the good
news is that compared to the real
ideologues Thomas Cavanaugh Gorsuch etc
John Roberts is not so ideologically
biased that he will even get the
technical decisions wrong that's a good
thing the reality is we still need to do
way better than Roberts and we certainly
need to do better than Gorsuch and
Cavanaugh and that's why one of the
important reasons for removing Donald
Trump and putting in Joe Biden remains
choices to the Supreme Court and
selections to lower courts as well we've
got a great bonus show for you today
producer Pat will be taking over the
reins I will be back with you on Monday
we are taking Friday off as a sort of
extended fourth of July holiday and then
we're back fully full power on Monday
I'll see you then